I'm looking for something to rev my
engine your engine walkabout to gambler
me joshing hasten today we're joined by
the star of mortal engines Hara Hillman
your character is so complex in this
yeah and she is layered yeah right you'd
be layered now what would you say I was
gonna say to you fill out a dating
profile for your character what would
the talk line bio be I don't know she'd
be gone like I'm wild mysterious and I
like to spend time on my own thinking
about who I'm gonna kill walks in the
dark at night and I don't know she would
sound like a serial killer a psychopath
yeah and also in this you do a lot of I
work it yeah I'm about that I wa I know
but you know scar but like did you have
to like channel your inner Tyra Banks
absolutely honestly we started off
filming everything with a scarf and
Christian kept coming to me being like
Hera I think like what do you what do
you expect me to do I'm I'm acting my
socks off with my eyes right now and
when they cover all this up you have to
start to do like way more like which
would look ridiculous if I didn't listen
very mobile eyebrows you got that I'm
like if I was gonna channel my inner
like here we're intense look yeah how
could I do it like really start to get
tension in your kind of my brows and and
just try to really focus on like what
gives your headache you know what I mean
we are basically going what just
thinking are you okay and then just sort
of peer your eyes a little bit like
you're like you can't really see so
maybe get the mouth a bit tense - yeah
it's real good yeah I think that was me
for a second I looked at you oh yeah
get me in the secret what is amazing
about this is you are a strong powerful
women in there what I find really crazy
about this is that still in 2018 you
going into interview
and people are saying to your strong
powerful women and how's that feel for
you personally how do you feel about
constantly being asked that question
when actually we would never actually
even ask them out it's a good question
because I think first of all this whole
idea of what is a strong woman is a very
kind of odd in a way because I think
what in films makes sometimes women and
female characters strong it's just that
they're actually properly written like
they have you know details they have
layers and genuinely think that we can I
read very often to characters from what
we see and and I think what's great
about Astor is that we see all these
colours as she goes in such a big
journey and in a way she's written like
so many male characters are written but
it's it's also that thing isn't it that
it's so easy to say like you know you're
strong woman right yet you know I'll
give that to you you know you're strong
you know but what does it mean like I
still want you know it's that thing you
can be strong but like are you gonna
give me the same screen time are you
gonna give you all of the layers of a
character and you know I don't know it's
strength is so many different things and
I'm you're strong in this well loving it
ah trying to